[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون ويندو اقدم
لكم اخبار الساعه سنخصصوا اخبار الساعه
الليله لتداعيات ارسال ذبابات ابرامز
وعليه وبارد الى اوكرانيا العناوين اجواء
ما قبل الحرب العالميه تتصاعد تحالف غربي
ضعيف والاسلحه الثقيله لاوكرانيا
بوتينا يجتمع مع قادته العسكريين للرد على
ارسال الغربي دبابات ثقيله لاوكرانيا
وبعد رفع الحظر الالماني دول التحالف
الغربي تتتسابق لاعلان عدد الدبابات
لاوكرانيا
التدريب والصيانه وطريقه التسليم اكبر
تحدي امام الغربي لنشر الدبابات في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ما خططت له الولايات المتحده
لتسليح اوكرانيا ذات امرا واقعا بعد اعلان
الرئيس الامريكي ارسال كتيبه كامله من
دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا تتكون من احدى
وثلاثين دبابات اكد ان الدبابات التي
سترسلها بلاده ستكون جزءا من اخرى مقدما
من الخلفاء لاوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان النشره
دبابات ابرامز في اوكرانيا سيحتاج الى وقت
وتدريب وستعمل واشنطن على ارسالها باقرب
وقت
تضايق عمل ناصر 30
دبابه ابرامز لاوكرانيا الامر الذي يكون
كتيبه اوكرانيا الوزير اوستن صاحب الخطوه
لانها تعزز قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
اراضيها وتحقيق الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
دبابات ابرامز هي الاقوى في العالم ومعقده
في التشغيل لذا سنمنح اوكرانيا قطع الغيار
والادوات التي تسمح بابقاء الدبابات عامله
في ميدان المعركه سنبدا بتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على تشغيلها في اسرع وقت ممكن
توصيل هذه الدبابات للمعركه سيحتاج وقتا
هذا الوقت سنستخدمه في التاكد من ان
الاوكرانيين قادرون على دمج دبابات ابرامز
في جيشها
كما شكل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
المستشاره الالماني اولاب شولز لدوري
برلين الحيوي في الدعم العسكري المقدم
لاوكرانيا واكد ان المانيا ستساهم بارسال
كتبتين من الدبابات لاوكرانيا
على دعمها اوكرانيا بمجموعه من دبابات
من الدبابات في اوكرانيا اشكر المستشار
الالماني على جهوده في دعم اوكرانيا
المانيا كان لها صوت كبير في المجتمع
الدولي من حيث الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا هذا
الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا في تعزيز قدرتها
على المواجهه في خطوط الجبهه
وفي اول رد فعل اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان الخطوه المقبله
ستكون المطالبه بمقاتلات اف 16 من دول
الناتو فيما اكد مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني اندريان ماك ان الولايات
المتحده ستعطي اوكرانيا 31 دبابه ابرامز
كبدايه للتعاون بشان الدبابات واضاف معك
ان بلاده ستستلم دبابات من الولايات
المتحده والمانيا وبريطانيا ومن دول اخرى
مؤكدا حاجته اوكرانيا لمئات الدبابات كما
اعتبر ان اليوم هو يوم تاريخي من ايام
ستحدد انتصار بلاده في المستقبل ايضا في
مقابله نشرتها قناه سكاي نيوز بريطانيه
اظهر مقطع فيديو تفاجئ الرئيس الاخرانيه
خبر اعلاني المانيا رسميا تثبيت اوكرانيا
لاكي شان
وائل متابعه كل هذه التطورات سانتقل الى
شبكه مراسلين من البيت الابيض ناديه
بالبيسي من برلين من موسكو عبد الجواد
الرشد من كانت حذيفه عادل اهلا بكم سابدا
معك ناديه الخبر اليقين من الولايات
المتحده وهذا ما عملت عليه حقيقه لوقت
طويل ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول ارسال
دبابات ابرامز وايضا موضوع المانيا
ارسالها ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا
تغيير كبير في الموقف الامريكي ميسون حيث
قررت اداره
المضيق قدما وارسال 31 من دبابات ابرام يا
ترى بان هذا سيغير ربما مسار المعركه كانت
هي متخوفه نوعا ما في السابق لانه كانت
ترى بان هذه الدبابات متطوره جدا بحاجه
الى تدريب كبير من الجيش الاوكراني هي
تستخدم كميه كبيره من الوقود وربما كان
هناك همم او هناك اشاره لانه بامكان
اوروبا ان تقدم دبابات اخرى بشكل اسرع
لانه كما تعرفين دبابات ابرامز كما قالنا
اليوم جون كاربي ستحتاج الى عده اشهر
لتسليمها الى القوات الروسيه لكن الاداره
رات بانه العقبه الوحيده امام المانيا هو
ان تبدا الولايات المتحده بالتسليح بهذه
الدبابات وبالفعل قرر رئيس اليوم الان عن
الالتزام تاييد عسكري غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا
وم روح وغير محدود يعني الالتزام طالما
هذه المعركه مستمره الاداره مستعده بان
ترسل كل ما يلزم الى الجيش الاوكراني طبعا
31 دبابه غير كافيه لانه اوكرانيا طلبت
اكثر من 200 تقريبا يقول باننا دعونا نبدا
الان بما نحتاجه او بما نحتاجه اوكرانيا
وسنوفر كل ما يطلبه الاوكرانيون لاحقا لكن
هي معركه بالنسبه لاداره الرئيس على طبعا
همم تجروا على ارض اوكراني البعض يراها
بانها معركه بالوكاله بين روسيا وبين
الولايات المتحده لكن الاداره ملتزمه
تماما وتقول بانها ستقوم بتذيب القوات
الاخرانيه وستقوم بتوفير هذه الدبابات ليس
من المخزون الوطن الامريكي لكن من الشركات
الامريكيه العسكريه التي تصنع هذه
الطائرات وتصنع معها كل التكنولوجيا
والصيانه التي تحتاجها وسترسلها باسرع وقت
ممكن على كل حال ناديه هذا ما حصل في
الولايات المتحده ولكن هذا الحماس
الامريكي حقيقه لارسال دبابات احد ابراج
قابلته ايضا موفقه المانيه رسميه لارسال
دبابات من طراز ليوبارد اثنين سنستمع الى
المستشار الالماني علب شوز قبل ان نذهب
الى زميلتنا راغبه بهنا
باي باي
الولايات المتحده بتقديم مركبات برادلي
وستقدم المانيا وفرنسا المزيد من
المساعدات سنقدم سته دبابات
وستكون من مخزوننا وسندرب المهندسين على
صيانه الدبابه
فيك فيك
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي يقول بانهم يريدون
من الغرب مقاتلات وصواريخ بعيده المدى
لمواجهه روسيا اذا بعد قبول الولايات
المتحده والمانيا وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
ارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا الان الرئيس
الاوكرانيه يتحدث بانهم ما زالوا بحاجه من
الغرب لمقاتلات وصواريخ بعيده المدى
لمواجهه روسيا ساذهب الان الى زميلتنا
راغده برنامج
كان مهما جدا بعد جدل كبير حول ارسال
الدبابات وسماح ايضا بارسالها من قبل دول
اوروبيه اخيرا المانيا اتخذت الموقف متى
لدينا من تفاصيل متى لدينا من تصريحاته
مواقف
مساء الخير ميسون وزير الدفاع الالماني
ووصف هذا القرار بانه قرار تاريخي وبالفعل
هنا يتم التعاطي او يعني الكلام على هذا
القرار بانه قرار مفصلي ومهم جدا هناك من
انتقد وجه انتقادات للمستشار الالماني
داخل البرلمان خاصه من حزب المعارضه
الرئيسي الذي تنتمي اليه مركز قال بانه
هذا التردد ربما ساهم به وضع او يعني
بتعطيل العلاقه بين الاولاد المتحده وبين
المانيا ولكن المستشار الالماني عاده
وتحدث وقال بانه العلاقه متينه مع
الولايات المتحده وخاصه مع الرئيس الجو
بايدن همم وعد وقال انه كان من الافضل ان
ننتظر غدا ان نذهب من فريدين يعني هذه هي
كانت النقطه المحوريه في كل هذه النقاشات
اليوم وتشديد يعني كان من هذه يعني لاصال
هذه الرساله من قبل المستشار الالماني
بانه هذه الانتظار لم يكن تردد بل كان
واجبا ضروره لكي لا ينظر الى المانيا على
انها ذهبت منفرده بتسليح الجيش الاوكراني
بهذه الدبابات المتطوره ولهذا في الواقع
يعني سببين اولا لتريد المانيا ان ينظر
اليها على انها هي السبب في تصعيدها هذه
الحرب وسبب ثاني بانه ارادت ان تاخذ همم
يعني همم اطمئنان اذا ما اردنا القول
الاخير بانه امريكا ملتزمه فعلا بحمايه
اوروبا والمانيا يعني وهذا العقد الذي هو
بينهم بينهما منذ ما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ولذلك اراد ان تكون هذه الخطوات
متوازيه همم منسقه بشكل كامل همم مع
واشنطن على كل حال ايضا سنذهب لمتابعه ما
يجري في اوكرانيا من مواقف وما يجري ايضا
في روسيا من مواقف اوكرانيا اعلنت قبل
قليل ان روسيا تزيد الزخم في معركه
دونيت وتحشد اعدادا كبيره فيما افادت
وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الرئيس بلازميه
بوتين سيعقد اليوم اجتماعا مع القيادات
العسكريه للبلاد للرد على قرار ارسال
الدبابات لاوكرانيا ونقلت تقارير صحفيه ان
الرئيس الروسي قد يغير الخطط العسكريه
بشكل كامل نتيجه لتطورات الجديده على
الارض هذه ابرز ايضا المواقف التي تحصل في
اوكرانيا وايضا في همم في روسيا ساذهب
الان الى زميلنا من مكياج حذيفه عادل
ليطلعنا ايضا على قبر التصريحات ابرز
المواقف وكيف تلقفت كاف هذه الاخبار التي
لا تعلم انتظارتها حذيفه
مساء الخير ميسون يعني اذا سمحت لي ان
ابدا بشعبيا شعبيا هنالك احتفال كبير جدا
من الاوكرانيين بهذه القرارات التي اسموها
في التاريخيه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تضج
بالاعلام الاوكرانيه في يعني في صفحات
المتابعين والمشاركين وايضا بصور الفهود
التي ترمز الى اليو بارك تو الدبابات
الالمانيه كذلك يعني على الصعيد الرسمي
والسياسي والقاده ايضا لاحظنا ان اغلبيه
القاده السياسيين سواء كان برضه ماليين او
مسؤولين في الدوله ايضا كانوا يعني يضعون
على صفحاتهم صور الفهود ويحتفلون بهذا
القرار طبعا الرئيس بلازا قبل قليل في
خطابه الاخير وصف هذا اليوم باليوم
التاريخ وكما اسمائه وتحالف الدبابات
الثقيله الذي يسمح الان بنقل هذه الدبابات
الى الجانب الاوكراني الان اوكرانيا لديها
يعني تشكيله من افضل
انواع الدبابات المقاتله الثقيله في
العالم ليوفر 2 وايضا ابرامز وشالنجر 2
وكذلك اي ام اكس 10 التي قال اليوم وزير
الدفاع الفرنسي انه سوف يتم نقلها الى كيف
في شهر فبراير القادم طبعا الرئيس زيليسكي
يعني حدد نقاط محدده هي الاهم الان هو عدد
هذه الدبابات عمليات الصيانه طبعا
والذخائر لهذه الدبابات وقال ان لديهود
يعني طبعا الشعب الاوكراني بان لديهود
بانه سوف يكون هنالك تدفق للذخائر لهذه
الدبابات وعمليات الصيانه وايضا هو علق
على عمليه السرعه في تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على استخدام هذه الدبابات كذلك
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وصف ايضا هذا اليوم
باليوم التاريخي وايضا شكر جميع الشرك
وعلى وجه الخصوص شرك الشكر طبعا وزير
الدفاع الامريكي وايضا المستشار الالماني
لا انتخابات هذه القرارات وقال ايضا ان
عمليات التدريبيه الاهم الان والسرعه في
تزويد كيف بهذه الدبابات وكذلك علق يرماك
وايضا وصفه اليوم باليوم المفصلي والتاريخ
الذي سيحدث النصر للجانب الاوكراني في
القريب طبعا اتحدث تحدث من الخبراء
العسكريين حول هذه الدبابات واهميتها
للمعركه القادمه طبعا تعلمين ميسوم ان
الحشد الان يتم له معركه الربيع كما سماها
العسكريين وهي الوقت الامثل لتحرك الاليات
والمدرعات في اي عمليات هجوم للمشاه لذلك
الان يقوم الجانبين بحجم الموارد كيما ان
تحسد الموارد لهذا التوقيت وهذه هي المده
التي سوف يتم فيها تسليم هذه الدبابات في
الجانب الاوكراني او قبل هذا قبل الربيع
سوف يتم تسليم هذه الدبابات وسيتم تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه سوف يكون هنالك تدريب
في بولندا وكذلك في المانيا هذا خلاف
عمليات التدريب التي ستتم اصل حاجه اخرى
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي
اسبانيا وفي بعض الدول الاخرى زملائنا في
اوكرانيا وايضا في المانيا وفي الولايات
المتحده اعطونا تفاصيل عن هذه القرارات
التي اتخذت اليوم من جانب طبعا هذا
التحالف لمواجهه روسيا الان ساذهب الى
زميلنا عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو ليعطينا
ردود فعل موسكو على هذه القرارات على
ارسال دبابات ليوبارد وايضا البرنس الى
اوكرانيا تفضل عبد الجواد ماذا لديك
ميسون بعد التحيه لكي والي الزملاء حتى
هذه اللحظه لا يمكن اخفاء قلق موسكو من
قضيه
تسليم الدبابات الغربيه لكيف طبعا موسكو
تحدثت رسميا ان كان على لسان
السفاراتها في برلين او في واشنطن حيث خرج
طبعا اليوم السفاره في المانيا وتحدث عن
ان موقف
المانيا من قضيه تسليم هذه الدبابات
الالمانيه اللي كيف هو موقف مسؤول ويصعب
الموقف بشكل خطير وقد يذهب بالعمليه
العسكريه الى تصعيد كبير خلال المواجهه
ايضا طبعا سفاره موسكو لدى واشنطن تحدثت
عن قيام الولايات المتحده بتسليم هذه
الدبابات وبتخاذ هذا القرار هو عمليه
جديده من شانها استفزاز موسكو بشكل جديد
خارجيه موسكو ايضا تحدثت بانها كانت على
علم بهذا بتوع وانا قضيه تسليم الدبابات
هي فقط لمواجهه روسيا عسكريا اما الكرملين
فراح يتحدث على لسان متحدثه الرسمي فيسكو
الذي خرج وتحدث بلهجه صارمه كما سماها
البعض وقال بان هذه الدبابات ان كانت
المانيه وان كانت امريكيه سيتم تدميرها
وتحويلها الى رماد وسيتم حرقها كما وصف
الموقف بشكل كبير
مثلا عبد الجواد بعد وصول هذه او ارسال
هذه الدبابات الى كاز بانجاز لو سمحت
ميسون كمان لاحظ بان موسكو مقدم بشكل كبير
على تصعيد العمليه العسكريه خلال الفتره
القادمه لكن طبعا بعد ما حدث اليوم على ما
يبدو ان موسكو ستاخذ تحركات جديده اما على
الملف السياسي من الجهه الملف العسكري من
الجنوب او طبعا على تحركات الضربات
الصاروخيه هناك بعض التكهنات بدخول من
يعني من من جانب الاراضي البيلاروسيه هناك
من يتحدث عن استخدام الصواريخ اسقى قد يتم
حملها بمقاتلات كبيره ايضا لاحظنا بان
موسكو اعلنت اليوم رسميا عن دخول دبابات
تي 80 وهي دبابات طبعا من العيار الثقيل
هي تشبه الى الى حد ما بشكل كبير دبابات
ارمامات التي دخلت الاراضي الاوكرانيه منذ
نحو شهر من الان هذه الدبابات تتمتع
بمواصفات قياسيه حسب رؤيه الخبراء
العسكريين ونلاحظ بان موسكو حسب القراءه
العسكريه السياسيه قد تدخل الان على مرحله
كبيره لم تشهدها الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
قبل ساعود الى زميلتنا ناديه ومن ثم الى
رغده لنسال عن ااا الشارع الامريكي
والشارع الالمانيه كيف يتلقف هذه الاخبار
لانه ناديه هناك بعض الاستطلاعات قالت
بانه نزلت
نسبه الناس الذين كانوا يؤيدون الوقوف الى
جانب اوكرانيا او ارسال اسلحه لها هل
لدينا من تفاصيل حول ذلك
هذا صحيح الى حد ما لكن اعتقد بان الاداره
والكونجرس يعني بالنهايه صانعي القرار في
الولايات المتحده هم الذين يتخذون قرارات
على هذا المستوى العالي جدا لانه تمويل
همم اوكرانيا طبعا عسكريا وتقديم كل ما
يلزمها من دعم يمتنعت عن تقديم ربما
الغطاء الجوي حتى الان لكن قدمت صواريخ
باتريت وغيرها والان نتحدث عن الدبابات
ابراز همم كان هذا ربما متعلق بموضوع
الاقتصاد والبطاله والتضخم والى اخره لكن
اعتقد بانه حتى المشككين في الكونجرس
والذين قالوا في السابق بانه لا يجب ان
نعطي اوكرانيا شكرا على بياض وخصوصا انه
هناك حديث عن حالات فساد وسوء استخدام
الاموال بالتحديد اليوم جون كربي نفذ ذلك
على الاطلاق كما قالت رغده اعتقد بانه هذه
هي دفاع عن حلف شمال الاطلسي عنها
الديمقراطيات الغربيه وبالتالي الشعب
الامريكي سي جيد الاداره والاداره
والكونجرس متفقان تماما بالنسبه
العسكري بالتحديد وسنرى بالفعل ربما حتى
مليارات من الدولارات في المستقبل القريب
ستقدم الى اوكرانيا على شكل مساعدات
الانسانيه واقتصاديه وعسكريه بالتحديد
الشارع الالماني هل هو متخوف من هذه
الخطوه
كان هناك استطلاع للراي النشر اليوم بعد
اتخاذ هذه او يعني صباحا عفوا قبل ان يصدر
هذا القرار ولكن اجري في اليومين الماضيين
اظهر بانه هناك بالفعل الانقسام همم لدى
الشعب الالماني رغم انه هناك يعني جزء
اكبر بقليل يؤيد ارسال هذه الدبابات 46%
يؤيد ارسالها وقرابه 44 يرفض والمتبقي لا
راي له همم ولكن المستشار الالماني حاول
اليوم
المتخوفين توجه اليه من تحديدا وقال بانه
للمتخوفين منه هذه الدبابات قد تؤدي الى
تصعيد الصراع والى ربما توريد المانيا انا
اقول لكم ثق به وثقوا بالحكومه انا لن
اسمح بان يتم تصعيد هذا الصراع وعد واكرر
بانه لن تتدخل ابدا لن تصبح ابدا همم طرفا
في هذا الصراع حتى في مرحله لاحقه عاد
وقال بانه لن نرسل مقاتلات ولا جنود المال
الى اوك شكرا
يا جماعه عبد الجواد الروش من كيف حذيفه
عادل شكرا لكم زملائنا
والان سنتوقف عن ما دعا رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك دعا الدول الغربيه
الى تعزيز دعمها العسكري لاوكرانيا في وقت
اكد الامين العام لحلف الناتو اكد ان
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه وتشالنجر
البريطانيه وليوبارد الالمانيه ستمكن
اوكرانيا من الانتصار بدورها اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الفرنسيه انها سترسل اول مركبه
مدرعه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار سي الى
اوكرانيا في شهر فبراير ان روج ايضا اعلنت
انها سترسل دبابات ليو بارد من المخزون
نهائي الى اوكرانيا فيما افادت وسائل
الاعلام المانيا اندرني ستقده تحالفا
اوروبيا لارسال كاتبته دبابات الى
اوكرانيا تتكون من 80 الى 100 دبابات
سلوفاكي ايضا بدورها اعلنت انها سترسل 30
دبابه من طراز تي 72 يعني
كماسات تناقش نقله مقاتلات ان اي جي 29
اليها وفي بي الامريكيه بريطاني الماني
فرنسي ايطاليه اكدت الدول الخمس على
التنسيق لارسال لامدادات الاسلحه الى كيرف
ايضا تداول نشاطى على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي صوره تظهر الدبابات ليوبارد
بالقرب من العاصمه الفنلنديه هلسنكي ووسط
المي حاتم بتجهيزها لشحنها الى اوكرانيا
من جانبها رفضت قوات الدفاع الفن الانديه
الميحات مستخدمي الانترنت مؤكده انه تم
ارسال الدبابات لاجراء تدريبات بالقرب من
مدينه هانكو جنوب البلاد
والان لمعرفه موقف فرنسا ساذهب الى باريس
مع حسين قنيبر زميلنا مراسل العربيه وايضا
لمعرفه موقف بريطانيا نعون نذهب الى لندن
ان معزومين مصطفى زارو حسين ابدا معك
بالنسبه
لفرنسا ابرز مواقفها تجاه هذه
الدبابات ارسال هذه الدبابات وابرز
المساعدات التي قدمتها وستقدمها ايضا في
الاونه اللاحقه
مساء الخير ميسون ابدا بالشق الاول من
سؤالك رد الفعل الفرنسي على موافقه
المانيا على ارسال دبابات ليوبارد 2 جاء
من خلال بيان للاليزا يعتبر ان الخطوه
الالمانيه
تعمق ما كانت فعلته فرنسا وهي امتداد
للخطوه الفرنسيه التي كانت قضت بارسال
دبابات او بالاعلان عن ارسال الدبابات
خفيفه من طراز ام اكس هذه الدبابات
الخفيفه ليست الدبابات القتاليه الثقيله
من طراز التي تطالب اوكرانيا بارسالها
وبالشقه الثانيه بالحديث عن الشقه الثاني
من سؤالك المعدات الفرنسيه اولا قبل
اندلاع الحرب بقليل ارسلت فرنسا خمسه عشر
مدفع من طراز
ثم بعد بدء الحرب ارسلت ثمانيه عشر
عامه من طراز السيزار الشهيره من عيار 155
ملم يصل مدى مدفع سيزار الى 40 كيلومترا
كما ارسلت الاف القذائف لتلقيم مدافع
سيزار ارسلتها فرنسا كما ارسلت صواريخ
مضاده للدروع من طراز ميلانو والغاما
مضاده للدروع وارسلت ايضا وسائل للدفاع
الجوي صواريخ للدفاع الجوي من طراز ميرال
كما ارسلت حواله 60 عربه خفيفه لمرافقه
المصفحات واعلنت في الرابع من هذا الشهر
عن ارسال دبابات خفيفه من طراز همم ام اكس
وارسالات ايضا معدات للوقايه من الهجمات
هل النوويه والفيولوجيه والاشعاعيه
والكيماويه وفرنسا على لسان الرئيس
ماكترونه اعتبرت ان ارسال دبابات يجب ان
يراعي في حال حصوله هذا ليس تبعدا لكنه
ليس قرارا واردا الان ولكن اذا حصل قرار
ارسال دبابات لوكلير القتاليه ثقيله يجب
ان يراعي ثلاثه معايير اولا الا تكون
الخطوه تصعيديه يقصد نكره هنا ان لا
تستخدم هذه الدبابات من قبل الاوكرانيين
لغايات هجوميه بالغايات دفاعيه ثانيا يجب
ان تامن هذه الدبابات في حال ارسالها دعما
حقيقيا وفعلا لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين وهذا
يحصل من خلال تاهيل الجنود الاوكرانيين
على كيفيه استخدام نرسله اليه من معدات
والمعيار الثالث الذي يجب ان يراعها كما
قال الرئيس الفرنسي خلال استقباله
المستشار الالماني الاحد الماضي الا يؤثر
اي ارسال لهذه الدبابات على القدرات
الدفاعيه لفران فرنسا بانه كما تعلمين
المخزون العسكري الفرنسي ليس كافيا بعد ان
تخلص فرنسا بعد الحرب البارده من قسم كبير
من مخزونها العسكري لتجنب نفقات صيانته
خصوصا بعد الاسماء الاقتصاديه في عام 2018
بريطانيا كانت دائما هي همم الاكثر تشددا
في موضوع مواجهه روسيا
وموقفها من حرب على اوكرانيا ما هو ما هي
رده الفعل اليوم على قبول الولايات
المتحده والمانيا ارسال هذه الدبابات وهل
من مساعدات جديده ستقدمها بريطانيا
للقرارات التي تم اتخاذها كان هناك اتصال
بين قاده خمس دول الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والمانيا وايطاليا بخصوص هذا الدعم
العسكري الذي تم التوصل اليه ولكن
بريطانيا اكثر تشددا سبقت ان اعلنت عن
تقديم حزمه همم
مهمه اكثر تطورا من بينها اربعه 10 دبابه
من نوع تشالنجر اثنين وهي الدبابه
القتاليه الرئيسيه للجيش همم البريطاني
بالاضافه الى مواصله تدريب الجنود
الاوكرانيين ما لا يقل عن 27,000 جندي تم
تدريبهم على الاراضي البريطانيه بالاضافه
الى ان همم الحكومه تعهدت بتدريب 10,000
جندي كل 120 يوما هذا بالاضافه الى حزمه
همم العسكريه التي قاربت مليار
300 مليون جنيه استرليني وتعاهد رئيس ريش
سوناك بانه سيبقى على هذه المساعدات همم
في العام في هذا العام الحالي هذا ما تم
تقديمه من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه العام
الماضي مع ان همم الكل يعرف بان كانت هناك
يعني حكومات متعدده لكن همم الموقف
البريطاني اتجاه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
لم يتغير وربما لعبت دور كبير بعد الاعلان
قبل 12 يوما على تقديم هذه المساعدات
العسكريه من بين الدبابات ان تدفع
بالشركاء الدوليين لتقديم مساعدات وخاصه
وان كما ذكر ريشه هناك بانك بوادر ايجابيه
من التقدم القوات الاوكرانيه همم على على
الجانب همم
بين الحدود مع روسي ولكن يبدو انها اقنعت
الشرك في تقديم هذا الدعم بشكل سريع شكرا
لك مصطفى زارو- زميلنا مرا العربيه من
لندن على كل هذه المعلومات ايضا اشكر
زميلنا حسين قنيبر من باريس على كل هذه
التفاصيل شكرا لكما
والناس
يموتون كل يوم انت تدرك انه لا يمكننا
القيام بذلك بانفسنا دون مساعده شركائنا
نريد الحصول على هذه الدبابات في اسرع وقت
ممكن
الدبابات
انا لا اشك في ذلك
اخر هذه اللحظه لفتره طويله نريدهم ان
يكونوا اكثر سرعه في المساعده وان يفهموا
اننا نحميهم
ايضا هذا الخبر العاشر على شاشه العربيه
الجيش الاوكرانيه يقول القوات الروسيه
تصاعد العمليات العسكريه في شرق البلاد
اذا حسب الجيش الاوكراني روسيا تصاعد
العمليات في شرق اللعب عموما المشاهدين
مساله تسليح اوكرانيا بدبابات متطوره ليست
سهله فالجزء الصعب هو كيفيه نقل المركبات
المدرعه الثقيله والشاحنات القتاليه
الاخرى الى ساحه المعركه وهو ما اكده
مسؤولون امريكيون لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الذين قالوا ان الامر قد يستغرق سنوات حتى
تصل دبابات ابرامز الى اي ساحه قتال
اوكرانيه في الوقت نفسه تدور مخاوف من
استهداف روسيا للطرق والسكك الحديديه او
لاماكن انطلاق المعدات اثناء الشحنها الى
الخطوط الاماميه في شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا ما
جعل الغرب يفكر بكيفيه ارسال هذه الدبابات
عبر قوافل خفيه عاده ما تكون متخفيه في
الظلام او مموهها لحمايتها من اي هجوم ايه
ده ايضا هناك تساؤلات عديده مشاهدينا طرحت
حول اهميه هذه الدبابات في ساحه المعركه
في حال وصولها اوكرانيا ترى ان الدبابات
ضروريه لاختراق الخطوط الروسيه ايضا
للتغلب على هجوم متوقع تحدثت عنه وسائل
الاعلاميه عده خصوصا ان دبابات ليوبارد
اثنين صمم تخصصا لتنافس الدبابات الروسيه
تي تسعه التي يستخدمها الروس في حربهم
ويعتقدوا الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان حوالي 300 دبابات ليو
باعد ست تساعد بلاده على هزيمه روسيا في
حين ان الاعلان الرسميه تحدث عن 16 دبابه
فقط
[موسيقى]
متابعه ايضا لهذا التطور الميدانيه
العسكريه وهو ارسال هذه الدبابات الى كافه
ينضم الى من واشنطن العقيد عباس دهوك
المستشار العسكريه السابق لوزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ايضا من موسكو ينضم الى المحلل
السياسي
اهلا بكما سابدا معك
كيف يمكن ان تستفيد اوكرانيا من هذه
الدبابات التي سترسلها الولايات المتحده
ابراز والمانيا والدول الاوروبيه الاخرى
والله قديم
اولا
وكما جاء في تقرير
لتعزيز القدرات القتاليه على الارض حتى
اللحظه
القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
يستخدمون هجمات
وهي افضل للدبابات حاليا في العالم فانا
من شانها ان ان يمنح
قتاليه كبيره في الماء في ميدان المعركه
وكما ذكرتهم ايضا ان هذا القرار الذي
اتخذته الولايات المتحده من الواضح يظهر
الاراده السياسيه وحاله الوحده التي
تعيشها الولايات المتحده ودوغ الاردني
وكذلك ايضا سوف يرفع من معنوياته القوات
الاخرانيه
بان الولايات المتحده واوروبا من تقف وانا
من خلفهم
وانهم كلهم متحدون من اجل ضمان
عدم فوزي روسيا في هذه الحرف اوكرانيا
الى اي مدى ارسال هذه الدبابات
سيعقد المهمه لديها سيصعد همم دور في هذه
الحرب
تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين والديك الكريم
انا لا اعتقد بها بالنسبه لروشه يعني
ارسال هذه الدبابات يمكن ان يعقل كثيرا
مجرى العمليه العسكريه الروسيه التي
تاخدها القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا لان
روسيا اولا كانت مستعده مثل هذا التطور
الاحاديث عن تصويت اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الاجرامي
ولكن اذا كنا واقعيين فان همم يعني وصول
هذه الدبابات كما قال همم
مسؤوله المانيا والولايات المتحده الذي
يحدث الا بعد اشهر يعني ربما ايوه تصل الى
اربعه اشهر بالنسبه للاخبار واطول فتره
بكل تاجيل بالنسبه لي ابرز يعني هذا يعني
ان روسيا خلال هذه الفتره همم حتى وصول
هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا يمكن ان
تتخذ مختلف الخطوات للاسراف في عمليتها
العسكريه في محاوله لحسم المعارك في شتى
الجبهات التي تدور فيها هذه المعارك الان
واخيرا هناك صعوبه ومشكله كبيره بالنسبه
للجانب الاولماني للجيش الاوكراني في
استخدام وصيانه وتصليح
واموره الروسيه اخرى متعلقه بهذه الدبابات
لان هو احتماما ان لا امريكا ولاء المانيا
ولا اي دوله اوروبيه سوف ترسل حتى فنيها
وخبراءها
لقيام به
السؤال الى ضيفنا من واشنط سيد دهوك ولكن
ايضا دنيا عند هذا الخبر العاجل مهم جدا
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه يقول قريبا
لن يكون لاوكرانيا اي منفذ على البحر اذا
لن يكون لاوكرانيا اي منفذ على البحث
ساعود الى ضيوف الكرام ولكن الان ساتوقف
مع اا بين مساند ومتخوف لاصوات الشارع
الالماني انقسمت هذه الاصوات بخصوص قرار
المستشار الالماني علب شوز ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا كما ذكرنا هناك من
رحب بالخبر ولكن هناك من اعتبره صبا
للزيتي على النار
اعتقد انه يتعين علينا مساعده اوكرانيا
والناس هناك هذا ما نقوم به بالفعل لكني
لا اعتقد ان المانيا يجب ان تشارك في
حربهم الى حصر لها
قرار جيد لم يكن هناك ايضا اي طريقه
للتغلب على ذلك وان اصبح المستشار محطه
سخريه العالم باسره
تجهيزا جيدا ولديها اسلحه افضل لكن هذا
سيضيف المزيد من الوقود الى النار
وسيزداد الامر سوء
ايضا مجدي داف يقول الان تعليقا على
دبابات
الدول النوويه الكبرى لا تخسر الصراعات
هذا موقف ايضا في ظل الاستمرار الولايات
المتحده بالتزام بها بارسال المساعدات
العسكريه الى اوكرانيا افاد استطلاع راي
الحديث بان غالبيه الامريكيين ما زالوا
يؤيدون ارسال هذه المساعدات غير ان تلك
الاغلبيه الحقيقه بحسب موقع ذال الامريكي
الاستطلاع اجرته شركه ابسوس ووجد ان اربعه
54% من الامريكيين يدعمون ارسال الاسلحه
الى اوكرانيا بعدما كان مستوى الدعم عند
59% في استطلاع المماثل اجرته الربيع
الماضيه ساعود ايضا الى ضيفيه من واشنطن
العقيد عباس له المستشفى العسكري السابق
لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن موسكو
والمحل السياسي يابني سيدرا سيد دهوك همم
كنا نتسائل الان سيدي في دينك كان يقول
بانه اربعه على الاقل حتى تصل هذه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا وفي هذا الوقت من
الممكن ان تصاعد روسيا وتحسم المعركه هل
هذا وارد
في هذه الاوقات لابد لهم من اعاده
حساباتهم وتعزيز قدراتهم الدفاعيه لكنه
صحيح ان فتره اربعه اشهر قد لا تكون مده
كافيه
لاعاده رسم ملامح المعركه بالنسبه لادخال
لهذه الدبابات الجديده فهناك الدعم
اللوجستيه ضروري من حيث ذيره وبعض قطع
الغيار والوقود
لدى حتى لو كانت هناك همم
مجموعه من 14
مؤلفه من 14 او 31 دباب من الطرزان فهذا
غير كافي للعمليه في اوكرانيا ثقافيه في
اوكرانيا كما تعلمون توجد جبهات طويله في
كافه انحاء البلاد وصولا الى شرقها الامر
يتطلب اعدادا اكثر من الدبابات مما سوف
يتم تقديمه لكن انه في نهايه الامر ومن
منظور يا سيف فان السياسيين ينظرون الى
هذه المساله انها قد تمنحهم حيزا من الوقت
لمعرفه ما يحدث على الارض يبدو ان روسيا
مستمره في عملياتها العسكريه ولم تتوقف
لذا فان هذه
لا اعتقد ان هذا سوف يجعل كافه الميزان
تميل علينا ان ننتظر لنرى ما قد يحدث نعود
ونذكر هذه الاخبار العاجله المهمه جدا في
تعليقا على دبابات الغرب لاوكرانيا قال
الدول نوويه الكبرى لا تخسر الصراعات وقال
ايضا خساره الدوله مثل روسيا لحرب تقليديه
يعني لحرب نوويه اريد منك تعليه صيدليه
على هذه التصريحات الخطيره الحقيقه هل
ارسال هذه الدبابات استفزت روسيا ومن
الممكن ان نصل الى حرب نوويه
انا ليه كلياتنا بين الاسلحه التي قد حصلت
اوكرانيا عليها حتى الان ربما انواع من
الصواريخ راجمات الصواريخ وغير ذلك من
المعدات والاسلحه
عن الدبابات التي ينوي الغرب بتصويده
فبالتالي يعني اذا كانت يمكن ربطه هذا
الموضوع موضوع
الامر الى حرب النوويه فانا لا اعتقد بان
مثل هذا الرابط الصحيح وهذا الاستنتاج
صحيح ايضا الامر الاخر هو بطبيعه الحال
اطاله ارض النزاع وهذا النزاع يكاد يتحول
الى مواجهه مباشره بين روسيا والدور
الغربيه وبالتالي هذا الامر بحرق ذاته
ينطوي على خطر كبير ولكن الحديث لا يعتقد
با يدور عن احتمال نشوبه حرب نوويه لان
الجميع
يدركونا تماما خطوره مثل هذا التحول لان
الحرب النوويه همم لا غالب فيها ولما وهذا
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن حالته بالقسوه تحسبا
لهجوم صاروخي روسيه واسع اشكركم ضيفي من
موسكو المحلل السياسي في جينيس دراف وايضا
من واشنطن على العقيد عباس لهوك المستشار
العسكريه السابق لوزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه شكرا لكم
في اخبار الساعه لدينا بعض لحظات النائب
العام في لبنان يطلق سراحه كافه الموقوفين
بقضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت والبيطار يرفض
التنحي عن الملف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على لبنان الى المربع
الاول في قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت مع
استئناف القاضي طارق البيطار التحقيق لكن
ثم ازمه قضائيه تعصف في افقي وزاره العدل
اللبنانيه راعيها الاول المناكفات
السياسيه اليوم اورده رويترز ان حزب الله
ايضا قرارات النائب العام بالافراجي عن
كافه المعتقلين مرفق بيروت في وقت كان
البيطار قد رفض التنحي عن الملف بعد ان
ادعي عليه النائب العام التمييزي غسان
عويدات وقال البيطار ان اي تعاون المعقول
الامني ما قرارات النائب العام التمييزي
تعد انقلابا على القانون لبنان في لبنان
ايضا خرج متظاهرون امام البنك المركزي
احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار بعد
سجلت الليره اللبنانيه انهيارا جديدا وصل
الى مستوى قياسي غير مسروق عند مستوى
55,000 ليره لبنانيه مقابل الدولار الواحد
واثر هذا الانهيار الجديد على اسعار السلع
والخدمات حيث محمد اصحاب المؤسسات الى رفع
الاسعار او التسعير بالدولار واغلاق
المحطات الوقود امام الزبائن الى حين صدور
تسعيره جديده للمحروقات تتناسب مع المستوى
الجديد الذي بلغته العمله الوطنيه تظهر
عراقيون امام البنك المركزي في العاصمه
بغداد احتجاجا على تدهور قيمه العمله
المحليه مقابل الدولار الامريكي هذا وقالت
وسائل اعلام عراقيه ان المئات من
المحافظات الوسط والجنوب وصلوا الى
العاصمه العراقيه حيث شاركوا في
الاحتجاجات فيما طالب المحتاجين الجهات
الحكوميه بالتدخل العاجل للحد من انهيار
العملاء وكان رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شيعه السوداني قد اثار الجدل باعاده تكليف
في علي محسن العلاقه في منصب محافظ البنك
المركزي بعد اكثر من عامين على اقالته
بسبب الاخفاقات الماليه التي حدثت في عهده
في الفتره السابقه
اخبار الساعه انتهت اشكر لكم ما طيب
المتابعه اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]